football hall of famer who knows a thing
or two about the tampa bay buccaneers
getting to the super bowl and winning it
he was a cornerstone of the team that
did it 18 years ago super bowl 37
champion
derek brooks joining us derek how are
you
pal doing all right mike and yourself
oh i'm doing great and and i just
noticed as the shot came up if there's
ever a shortage of footballs in the
world you will make a lot of money
oh man oh my god don't thank me my wife
she
uh found all these balls that i
collected and she kind of put together
this thing behind me so uh
i pretty much kept every uh interception
of test down uh that i was involved in i
kept the ball and
uh she found him and this was she got
set up behind me
oh it looks awesome she did a great job
what's the one ball that you would never
part with
oh uh i would say
all of them but probably the
interception for touchdown is superbowl
37 that's
that is one that uh
i really i had to keep close to my arm
after that game
i mean i didn't let it go i didn't trust
the equipment manager with it
i didn't trust family
i kept that ball the whole time so i
would probably say that's the one
uh i would not part ways
you're on the host committee for this
super bowl how different is this super
bowl just the fact that fans aren't
going to be there like they normally
would the media is not there like that
like it normally is and how unfortunate
is this for for tampa the city of tampa
which you know wanted this super bowl
and now has it but it's going to be so
different
well serene i was i would say that we're
not taking the attitude of it's
unfortunate we're
taking the attitude that we're taking
advantage of everything that we do have
and we do have a great game that we're
celebrating with our team the bucks
celebrating the first part of history by
getting here
uh it's going to be enough people
watching and participating that's
rooting them on to be a part of this now
obviously things have changed when it
comes to the media and your guys
covering the game and you've uh and your
colleagues have had to make that
transition all year long so we look at
this as you guys are used to doing this
in this same space and place we just
want to make sure you guys continue to
have all the access points that you've
had in previous years when it comes to
a super bowl now yes we've had to
rewrite the blueprint no doubt about it
everything that we've learned the past
few years
we've had to throw half of it out
and pivot and make audibles and
adjustments to
make sure that everything involving
safety and healthcare and protocols are
first and foremost
in all of our fans uh lives
and we're still having some of familiar
events we just scaled back obviously the
number of participants when you have to
limit the capacity so we've tried to
keep all the fan experience things in
we just have to reduce the amount of
access in terms of fans being able to
attend
so uh yes we hopefully we set the stage
for the cities that's coming behind us
that they don't have to start from zero
like we did
hey derek when you played for the
buccaneers you made number 55 legendary
there's now a linebacker on the team
wearing number 45. when you see devin
white what is your reaction
uh explosive play maker
you can see he's getting even more
comfortable in his in this defense which
is taking advantage of his skill set
obviously they drafted him where they
drafted him to be a playmaker and an
impact player and devon has done that at
the same time mike i do have to
recognize the young man beside him
lavontay david and i think levonte has
been
one of
probably the most consistent players for
a long time in this league that hasn't
gotten the attention and i think levante
and him playing together do a good job
of complementing each other's skill set
so i really like to think that levonte
has built into the development of devon
white but devin white has definitely
come on and shown that he's ready to be
the leader of that defense
derek you guys won with defense back in
your day and this team is so much more
on on offense but if you had to draw up
a game plan to stop patrick mahomes what
would you do how would you stop him
well irene i know you got some problems
from kansas city people watching this
thing so i don't want to get away
[Laughter]
you know some some conversations that i
may or may not have had
but i'll say this here's here's what
they can do if you go back and look
obviously at the raiders and even last
year's super bowl there's a formula
there that teams have had success with
and
the books
but believe it or not it can be a very
similar in terms of their game plan yes
you're gonna have to uh offensively
you're gonna have to help your defense
when you're playing patrick mahomes in
this offense by having a consistent
running game that eats up clock
defensively
they've done a good job of getting
turnovers in the playoffs so they've got
hot at the right time and creating
pressure in creating turnovers and with
patrick and his offense with kansas city
gives you an opportunity to get a
turnover you have to take advantage of
it meaning if you're going up for an
interception you got to come down with
the ball it can't be a fast breakup when
you have him corralled in the pocket you
have to bring him down do not let him
extend plays and escape and make the
plays using his god given ability that
he's made and creating uncomfortable
pocket and lastly i will say this
they have to take away kansas city's
running game
that is how kansas city got back in the
super bowl last year against san
francisco by running the football and
creating an opportunity for downfield
passing plays and they did a great job
of that at green bay and taking away the
running game from aaron rodgers and
obviously when they were able to do it
they made plays against aaron
defensively so
i would say very similar game plans
obviously different skill sets when it
comes to these teams but that to me is
is a pathway of success when you're
going against an explosive offense and
at the end of the day you make it a
physical football game
derek the buccaneers were seven and five
going into a week 13 bye week they're
7-0 cents then the offense gets so much
of the attention i think we overlook
collectively how much better the defense
has gotten where have you seen the most
improvement on the defensive side of the
ball the past seven games
uh they've got healthier and you go back
to the second half of that atlanta game
that defense came out the second half
and they've been on a roll as i said
before whether it was creating pressure
and turnovers
to even scoring themselves in winning
the field position battle and that's
where i think
the tom brady experiment the tom brady
expertise in tampa
really showed up
when the bucks were seven and five and
struggling because they've been in
similar positions in the years past
and they've not won enough games to get
in the playoffs when they was reeling
down the stretch this year
i think tom being in the leadership
position was able to influence this team
keep this team together and they haven't
looked back since the second half for
that atlanta game that's why i think
again his experience has influenced the
entire football team but you're right
mike the defense you know as well as
they've been playing yes
you're going to give up yards in today's
game
but you play well
in the red zone and you create turnovers
in today's game that equals good defense
now obviously when i played that was
considered terrible if it's giving up
all those yards but in today's games the
offense is going to get yards you just
do what you can to prevent them from
scoring in the red zone and when you
have an opportunity to get a turnover
you have to get turnovers
derek we talk a lot about the tampa two
defense you and warren sapp off that
defense or in the hall of fame maybe
it's the tampa three different defense
after this year
your buddy john lynch is is up for the
hall of fame again a finalist and i've
presented him a couple times now uh and
so is ira kaufman from from the tampa
bay area but what would it mean for john
lynch to go into the hall of fame in
tampa with you guys it would be pretty
special wouldn't it
yes at first i do want to thank you for
you know
taking my phone calls and listening to
every year you're listening to my
political speech as i make an argument
in a case with john
and even rondae and simeon so again
thank you for
uh really asking a question and seeking
information
but how fitting would that be if john or
rondae was able to get in
the team is playing and making history
at least by playing in the super bowl
it's super bowl 55 which always has a
special ring to it personally but to see
my good friends one of them you know one
of them get in
you know it's just a little bit more
than icing on the cake obviously john
has been waiting the longest uh of any
of the finalists
and i think obviously he's deserving of
that
honor years ago so i hope this year is
the year in rendez
uh by getting in that top 10 you never
know what happens but i do believe uh
with my heart of hearts and including
simeon rice that all three of them have
hall of fame resumes and deserve to join
warren and myself as well as
neighborhood sellman
as tampa bay buccaneer hall of famers
hey derek last one for you john gruden
was the coach of the team that won super
bowl 37
never got back with the bucks couple of
playoff appearances after that and now
three years in as raiders head coach
after a long break not able to get back
to the postseason do you see it turning
for gruden and him getting back to the
postseason on a regular basis with the
raiders
yes i do and i think each year mike
they've gotten a little bit better i
think john has adjusted
to his long layoff you know from the
league and saw that this is a different
league that he's come back to than when
he left and i think they made a good job
of that a good job of adjusting
you look at the changes he's made this
offseason on the coaching staff i'm very
impressed with this staff that he has
right now and i believe in it because i
know him and i believe in them that they
can get things turned around it doesn't
matter that they're in the same division
as kansas city because they showed
last year that they can not only play
with them but they can beat them so i
think the changes that john has made
he's finally got everything solidified
and now just again as he might continue
to uh adjust the personnel to the
schemes that they have i still think the
raiders can get back and they make an
even bigger jump next year
hey derek awesome stuff we appreciate
you we appreciate your time
congratulations on all your success and
all the best this week as we get ready
for super bowl 55.
uh congratulations to you guys and as
always it's fun seeing you on tv and
listening to you and you give my buddy
chris sims a break man you're really
hard on chris
i love chris
all right he makes it easy to be hard on
him thanks man take care that's derek
brooks hall of famer super bowl 37
champion
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports